た
[音楽]
[拍手]
うん
[音楽]
みなさんこんにちは
鹿児島下のイナゴはシャレになりません
私があったでしょうか
社会人でしょうかそれとも高校生でしょうか
この通り高校生です
僕はこの x-ばにお招きいただき何を貼りするかというと
高校生だからといって勉強の話でも
2まだ恋愛の話でもありません
x- ead 4りーすプレーティング worth ではなくスプレー t グラブ
しかないありませんし
影響立位ではこう
といっ
数学の点数は言い過ぎでたまに成績のグラブが出てきてこないことだってあるんです
そっ
られていたほかのグラフが大きいガード点数打ったか
3 gt r 今回を控えさせて頂きますがなのでこのように米帝はできない僕がぺー
今日の話をし
はできません
では何を何するのかというとこちらです
自分を大きく集です
もちろん
小料理になりたいとは背を高くしたいと思う
そういう大きくショーではなく
自分を内から大きく吸っについて僕の経験前でお話ししようと思います
僕の話は誰か一人でも多くの方のこれから参考になっていただければ幸いです
まず僕は何者か
優勝から説明しようと思います
北にある消去ミニジャイアンという言葉がぴったりな6
やんちゃう
窓ガラサー美味しい
uj ニャンター32社倉庫の鍵を生みやり開けようとして鍵穴に枝突っ込んで鍵を
交換しなければならないと
本当にあんじゃん
日本書紀で車
スマート小学校就学を盗み部活のバスケットボールと
喰らうジャム陸上水泳をして中学校中学校はスポーツに染まった住民印鑑でした
今ほんとこの辞令感とでもはい
いう感じ早く過ぎたように感じます
スマートなんだかんだ
事件あり声で今も在籍している鹿児島芸術コーナー行動が母乳しました
ん
このど田舎育ちも木ので
傾聴し第一の大都会にある高校のいうことで
毎朝し下がりいっぱいしてくれば校に行くんだろうなぁなんていう
またれたこと考えら
入学しましたん
でもよくよく考えてみると毎朝まで1杯400円の合否を待って
がこの投稿するとなる
年間通して10万円を使えばに費やされてやりません
あっ
到底そんなことありません車
スマホなりギャップを感じながら言うと
また55生活車
二契機に勉強5位デーは子元気に培った知識6
的今なぜ休みで通り使い果たし日レビュー学力はさあでいきました
スマート
高校1年生の3月に中止を植えバス敬語を対応したいと
やっとラビアカーに見えるがどうもいいよ
涙のは
弊社の時刻表を覚えるグルですあったからからぁっ
同じな分の姉シングルた微量な次男鳥はコーデで味な分ぐらいナースこの交差点を通っ
て
6ぐらいの位置の方みんなで歌えばいいそうすれば停車にされる
その後ばっかり考えていましたん
それでも来られない高校生活の言いましたがあります
終わり明日それにやばいぞと思いません
でもそんな時ある古い透明しましたん
ハービー uk の参加者を募集しますのグリッドです
学び buk とは何かというと
2年生の構成や分40名が世界
地域日本の人口問題に焦点はで各個人で課題研究をもらい最終的に英語でのプレゼン
発表会で代表中4名がフリースの多くそうだよクエ県命じたよって研修を行うという
ものです
じゃこれを右下と記憶を持ったことを言っ
難しそうだなと思いましたん
es ケープ1総論
なんか価格の構造死ぬんじゃないかなといえば
はぁ
僕の店にとってとっても理解するの難しく
僕とはかけ離れたエリートだけするものだと思っていません
しかし長過ぎ申し上げますが僕はこの事業に参加してイギリスに行くことができました
では何が6
この何の取り柄もねー
お昼しかうできないような普通の高校生をつけようかしたのか
ん
アクション素晴らしいと思いだったらすぐ行動です
何もかもが初めてだった僕はッ
か台形型のセミナーなどに積極的に参加し
僕は課題研究で高齢者
京急車ですが
こんな機会があったら高齢者の方がいい
湯浴槽政府なんと感じでー
こんな機会をつけていましたん
て機械のチャンプはプログラミングはゼロから学んで一から作り上げる
長いました
これはたんですか母
なんか自分できるじゃんております
数学に重点
シミは受ける僕はこのよりいつも一 s 身近道です招待する時が4 a
まあからこのお手製の枕です
を切り出しへ
大聖堂です
この枕それが正しい入れ方はアドでまだ
チラッ版
では真っ向な呼吸でですよ何度かよね高校雪ヒョウガシャもは先ほどもそうだ
もうしました握手んファースト一歩を踏み出す行きです
これまでは何が入って今年かーって思う
自分は気はできないじゃないぞ
失敗するんじゃないかとかっ
自分の頃に自分で米を売ってしまっていました
このコールの霊言せいで取り返しが細胞がやししたのだと思います
皆さんは公開を過ぎですか
ボクは嫌いです
何か新しいことをやりたいというペダルはこれいう風に言っ
そこに失敗したらどうしようとか自分ができないというネガティブな気持ち
つまりコールまで影響をかける
気持ちよく成長甘い進めるでしょ
ですん
何倍も進みづらいになるでしょうか
いやー気持ちよく前に進めるたりー
夢は細く捉えるためにどうすればいい
そう
心のブレーキを緩めるのです
これにブレーキを全開にしてどんどん前に進みましょう
どんな小さな声でもいいんですよ一歩前に進んでみてください
ここでは次がいたに染まることも0系を話したからといってそうなると思う
まだまだいう形でていうか両手放し運転者からです
そういうこともありません
安心して掘る0経由でどんどん前に進んでください
そうすればきっといなや colors です
自分のファイルファンの80%は技術やならない
僕は僕自身とチッ僕自身の経験として
このことも実感しました
まあ未だ本当にできるのかなと思っている方もいらっしゃると思います
でもよく考えてくださいこの僕ができないんです
お昼寝大好きあっ背景もできないまま僕らができません
皆さん一方ないですねみてください
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]